.
DAN: STAY SAFE, TREY, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
DID HE WALK HIMSELF INTO A
GUERRILLA WAR?
IT'S ONE THING TO TAKE A CITY
LIKE KYIV.
BUT IT'S AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
THING TO OCCUPY A GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE A STRONG SENSE
OF NATIONAL IDENTITY WHO DON'T
WANT TO BE OCCUPIED?
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF, IS
THIS GUY SANE?
IS VLADIMIR PUTIN THE SAME
PERSON WE WERE DEALING WITH JUST
SIX MONTHS AGO?
WHAT CALCULUS WAS HE GOING
THROUGH IN HIS HEAD THINKING A
CITY OF 3 MILLION PEOPLE WITH A
STRONG NATIONAL IDENTITY.
EDUCATED GROUP OF PEOPLE WITH A
LONG HISTORY.
ARMED NOW, 3 MILLION PEOPLE,
MANY OF THEM ARMED.
DID HE THINK TAKING THE CITY WAS
GOING TO BE AS EASY AS OCCUPYING
IT?
DID HE WALK HIMSELF INTO A
GUERRILLA WAR HERE?
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS A STRONGMAN.
I DIDN'T SAY A MAN WHO IS
STRONG.
THAT'S NOT THE SAME THING.
HE'S A STRONGMAN.
HE REQUIRES THIS A TINA, THIS
MASK -- THIS PATINA, THIS
STRENGTH.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AS HE
CONTINUES TO BOMB APARTMENT
BUILDINGS.
DESTROY UKRAINIAN OIL DEPOTS AND
THE BODY BAGS START TO MOUNT UP.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN HE LOSES
SUPPORT AT HOME?
RUSSIANS AREN'T EVEN POLLING A
MAJORITY IN SUPPORT FOR HIM
TRYING TO KEEP UKRAINE OUT OF
NATO WHICH WASN'T EVEN ON THE
TABLE.
THAT'S ONE THING ABOUT
STRONGMEN.
THEY AREN'T DEMOCRATICALLY
ELECTED.
THEY REQUIRE THIS DECEPTION OF
STRENGTH THAT WILL BE SLOWLY CUT
OFF AT THE KNEES AT 3 MILLION
REALLY PISSED OFF UKRAINIANS
START TO SNIPE AT THESE RUSSIANS
FROM APARTMENT BUILDINGS IN
KYIV.
YOU KNOW IN MY PRIOR LINE OF
WORK I DID A LOT OF WORK ON
TRANSPORTATION SECURITY.
IT WAS NOT WAR AND I DON'T MEAN
TO COMPARE IT TO WAR.
BUT YOU ARE SECURING THE LIFE OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
TO SECURE EVEN A FIVE OR
SIX-MILE MOTORCADE ROUTE.
YOU ARE TALKING HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND
PERSONNEL INVOLVED JUST TO MAKE
SURE THE PRESIDENT CAN TRAVERSE
SAFELY FROM A TO B.
VLADIMIR PUTIN THINKS HE WILL
OCCUPY A CITY OF 3 MILLION
PEOPLE WHERE THEY DON'T WANT HIM
THERE WHERE THE WHOLE CITY IS
HIGH GROUND AND THEY ARE ARMED?
IS HE WALKING HIMSELF INTO A
GUERRILLA WAR?
I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE HIM TO
REMEMBER THE WORDS "THE VICTOR
IS NOT VICTORIOUS UNTIL THE
ADVANTAGE WISHED CONSIDER
THEMSELVES SO."